l'espace. Le volcan sous-marin
Hunga Tonga-Hunga Ha'apai a Ha't
entré en éruption dans le sud
du Pacifique.
La force des explosions,
entendues à des milliers de
la panique. Des vagues de plus
d'un mètre ont déferlé sur
les îles Tongas, situées à
65 kilomètres au nord dBARDINTZ,
volcanologue
- Une éruption sous-marine,
quand elle est peu profonde,
explosif. On croit que l'eau va
éteindre le volcan, c'est
l'inverse. L'eau se vaporise et
augmente l'explomble et donc ona
des éruptions très violentes.
- Les résidents ont fui tant
bien que mal vers les hauteurs
plus de 100 000 habitants.
Les torrents ont dévasté
cette église.
Pris daffronaffronaffronaffronan
de la musique des îles.
♪ ♪ ♪
Les cers sont retombées sous
la forme d'une pluie noire.
JOHN STIX, volcanologue,
Université McGill
le soleil à 100% dans certaines
zones. C'est com C'est com C'est
là-bas pendant la journée.nt
également déferlîles
Fidji, à plus de 800 kilomètresé
l'alerte.
- C'est des vagues qui vont très
vite. Elles vont à peu près à
700 km/h et elles peuvent
augmenarrivaarrivaarrivaarrivaa.
(bruit des vagues )
Puis, les vagues ont finalement
frappé les côtes californiennes,
ici, à Santa Cruz.
(sirènes)
Les alertes au tsunami ont
aussi forcé les évacuations au
Britannique, plus éloignées de
l'éruption, font aussi fac
un avis de tsunami. Le volcan
n'en est pas à ses premières
il a expulsé sa colonne de fumée
à une vingtaimètres
dans les airs et son avenir
demeure incertain.